parody music videos have millions of
views on YouTube but the trend is
nothing new sure
weird al' has been doing this since the
seventies but for centuries composers
including Mozart and Bach's have
satirized the works of their peers hey
it's nice old Ellie and I are going to
create a parody of a very famous theme
song but first let's find out why people
have satirized each other's works for
hundreds of years
so what is parody parody music copies
existing musical ideas lyrics or style
in a certain artist or genre usually
just for laughs
although parody is often silly the US
justice system takes it very seriously
when arvind berlin sued Mad Magazine for
creating parodies of his music the US
Court of Appeals sided with mad writing
we believe that parody and satire are
deserving of substantial freedom many a
true word is indeed spoken in jest
parody has always been a thing making
fun of other forms and people recognize
the form and it just elevates the humor
there may be other humor going on but if
you're mimicking a form that's a whole
nother layer that people enjoy seeing so
for people who get the joke or lately
they feel part of the group is that why
humans love it
absolutely that's how humorous that's
just another interesting way connect
people but parody in music hasn't always
been a joke in 1749 your own special
Bach completed one of his last
compositions before his death mass in B
minor this parody mass includes
substantial portions of pre-existing
music both written by Bach and other
composers this might sound like
plagiarism but at the time it wasn't
seen as stealing quoting famous
compositions was a way to honor other
composers Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart wasn't
always as respectful in its composition
called a musical joke Mozart ridiculed
what he felt were the lesser composers
of this day
so oddly enough some of the harmonies he
uses here because they're intentionally
wrong are actually quite progressive
because later on other composers would
use these types of harmonic techniques
there are a lot of parts in this that
are supposed to be deliberately so in C
major
[Music]
and so how we end up in a flat the
endings a giant joke
obviously Austrian composer Johann
Strauss also satirize contemporary
composers in his purpose to mobile a
opus 257 the bouncy cartoonish style
poked fun at popular music of the day
that was really heavy on flashiness but
light on musicality it's ready to go on
forever and the score actually calls for
the conductor to pick a point to stop
the musicians turn to the audience and
save and serve ITER which means and so
on by marrying the stylistic nuances of
other artists and then twisting them for
comedic effect Mozart and Strauss show
that they understood exactly what other
composers were doing and that they
thought it was ridiculous
in 1913 Eric sativa wrote a composition
for the piano titled and we owned the
sachet or desiccated embryos each of the
three short movements were named for
scavengers of the sea he wasn't
lampooning just one composer but rather
the classical music establishment which
he felt was stuck in the past for
example you probably recognize the third
movement of Chopin's piano sonata number
two written in the 1830s
[Music]
now listen to satis second movement
written more than seven decades later
[Music]
by calling out well-worn conventions of
past composers in this way s'ti created
as literary theorist Linda Hutcheon put
it critical distance from which the
audience can see the past in a new light
parody can do more than just make fun of
your competition it can also be used to
fight Nazis Spike Jonze was one of the
first American parodies to achieve
widespread commercial success his hit
their features face written by oliver
wallets was a key piece of anti-nazi
propaganda during world war ii the
cartoonish anthem reduced the Third
Reich to slapstick comedy it was an
instant hit renowned American librettist
Oscar Hammerstein called it a great
psychological song of the war for
fighting Nazis I'm feeling a light too
decent 9:00 on this record over the next
few decades there been a handful of
American music parodies who enjoyed
saying like the Grammy award-winning do
well homer and Jethro sometimes
described as the thinking man's
hillbillies and Alan Schurman whose 1964
album my son the folk singer was the
fastest selling record up to that time
hello mater hello father
but since the 80s Weird Al Yankovic has
been by far America's most recognizable
music paradis the big-haired accordion
wielding musician has parodied acts from
Queen to Lady gaga
doing so in a light-hearted way that he
describes as more of a poke in the ribs
than a punch in the face
we're doused expertly crafted lyrics fit
like puzzle pieces on top of familiar
songs his parodies captured the essence
of the original work down to the finest
detail besides his talent one reason
Weird Al shot to fame was a symbiotic
relationship with MTV which was just
becoming popular in the 1980s with the
ability to parody a song and its music
video I was able to add new dimensions
to his parodies background gags and
sight gags allow you to flesh out the
humor a lot he once said
30 cm wide alert and it gets me by
nailing these seemingly trivial details
weird out provides a perfect example of
the key ingredient to a great parity
verisimilitude or mirroring the object
of parity as closely as possible the
National Lampoon in the 60s raised the
bar and what they started doing was
employing professional design and
typesetting to do parodies that looked
exactly like the thing that they do and
then when we did the onion we wanted it
to look exactly like a newspaper and
what that does it makes it so much
funnier for the people who are in on the
humor of course modern parity music
isn't limited to Weird Al comedy acts
like Adam Sandler and Tenacious D
created parody albums that went platinum
in the 2000s parody music hit premium
cable with HBO's Flight of the Conchords
a show starring the deadpan New Zealand
duo that painting groups like the Pet
Shop Boys to sit down but you sold your
chest so yeah you just stand there
the advent of YouTube made it easier
than ever for people to produce and
access parody music now every time a
song becomes a hit you can expect
YouTube paradis to cover it within days
everybody loves parody songs and here's
why first of all people love music
because it's pure emotion and people
also like humor but it's very different
humor is a very intellectual process so
the combination of those two things
that's what makes it one of the most
powerful single entertainment formats
there is so la how are you gonna create
this parody piece I think we should do
the bonnie theme song were your phantom
Bonnie growing up I was a huge Barney
fan okay I was I had a Barney backpack
let's get it
I had a Barney bedspread dude yeah and a
little bunny stuffed animal you like
that big I took them everywhere okay so
what if we tried this plug it into a
completely different genre I kind of
like that idea
turn the Barney theme song into
something that's very cool no matter who
you are you know the lyrics I love you
you know the Barney you know I love you
You Love Me we have family why don't we
also add in something that's musically
funny does a beat never drop
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]